[Musique]
cette capacité à être crimes très
rapidement attention petit quizz rapide
depuis combien de temps on n'a pas
tourné une vidéo anecdote sur sa chaîne
Youtube c'était un an et demi bravo
pourquoi on n'a pas trouvé une vidéo
anecdote depuis longtemps parce que j'ai
tout raconté sur cette chaîne Youtube
d'accord ça fait 10 ans carrément j'ai
raconté tellement de trucs des fois je
parle à des amis je leur raconte un truc
et il m'arrête il me faut un temps tout
de suite tu l'as raconté dans une vidéo
je connais déjà l'histoire je vous ai
essentiellement raconté dans toutes ces
vidéos anecdotes des trucs qui me sont
arrivés quand j'étais plus jeune quand
j'étais soit ado voire même enfant pour
pas mal d'entre elles aujourd'hui c'est
des trucs que j'ai vécu au cours
quasiment que de la dernière année je
vais pas raconter trois anecdotes
contrairement à d'habitude je vais en
raconter deux mais les deux c'est le
même thème c'est des rencontres badantes
il m'est arrivé deux trucs où j'ai pensé
à vous au moment où ça m'est arrivé je
me suis dit ça y est je vis un [ __ ] de
trade d'horreur c'est mon tour c'est ma
propre histoire que je vais bientôt
raconter et c'est la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
première anecdote on est en mars 2020
c'est le premier confinement premier
confinement c'est-à-dire le confinement
que les gens ont respecté de fou et moi
je vous cache pas pendant ce confinement
j'avais deux petits plaisirs le premier
c'était de Live beaucoup plus
qu'habituellement parce qu'il y avait
plein de gens qui étaient devant l'ordi
et c'était il y avait une bête
d'ambiance sur internet en vrai beaucoup
plus que dans la vraie vie nous sommes
en guerre et j'avais un deuxième kif que
plein de gens ont eu ici c'est sûr ce
qui avait des chiens c'était sortir
Natsu pourquoi c'était beaucoup plus
kiffant que d'habitude parce que je
pouvais marcher au milieu de la route
j'en avais rien à [ __ ] Paris c'était
devenu ma ville mec j'avais l'impression
d'être le shérif c’était une ambiance
trop bizarre et hyper agréable pour tous
ceux qui avaient un chien parce qu'en
gros on était les seuls à voir le droit
de sortir et jamais j'aurais imaginé
marcher dans Paris désert bref on est
jeudi soir le jeudi soir vous savez si
vous êtes un secours de qualité je suis
en live surtout twitch oh petit auto
promo La vite fait ce soir là je sais
pas pourquoi mais le live il finit tard
il finit autour de 3h du mat comme tous
les soirs et comme à chaque fois que
j'ai fini de Live je prends Natsu et je
le sors mais ce soir là je vais me taper
un kiffe je me dis [ __ ] Paris est vide
je veux voir les Champs-Élysées vides et
marcher au milieu de la route petit kif
bizarre inédit je pourrais plus jamais
le faire j'arrive sur place je suis au
milieu de la grande avenue pas un bruit
autour de moi pas une voiture pas une
personne juste moi Natsu et l'Arc de
Triomphe mais petite gâche quand même ce
soir là c'est le soir où il y a eu une
méga tempête à Paris je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez il y avait un vent de
malade il pleuvait à torrent je suis au
milieu de cette lui battante c'est beau
ça fait des reflets par terre ça c'est
un peu les moments où tu mets du Nekfeu
dans tes oreilles tu mets les étoiles
vagabondes tu marches seul et tu te dis
quoi tu te rends en bas de là vous voyez
pas bref je marche je suis en train de
remonter la venue des Champs-Élysées et
que vous jouez loin un homme qui court
très vite et qui court très vite vers
moi au début je m'inquiète pas plus que
ça et puis je me dis attends attends il
y a personne dehors à part moi c'est
forcément vers moi qui court et il se
rapproche il se rapproche il se
rapproche et qu'est-ce que je fais moi
comme une énorme victime écoutez moi
bien je fais un petit angle droit pour
retourner sur le trottoir en mode genre
pile à ce moment-là comme par hasard
j'ai une petite envie c'est marcher sur
le trottoir et puis j'entends les bruits
de pas qu'il s'accentue qui s'accentue
et je comprends que tiens comme par
hasard le gars aussi décidé de prendre
la direction du trottoir c'est étrange
ça et là il se passe qui devait arriver
le mec me fait hé quand ça m'arrive ce
genre de truc je nie je suis dans le
déni le plus total le déni c'est
regarder Natsu faire allez Natsu tu
marches du coup je m'éloigne avec mon
téléphone dans la main et le gars
continue de me parler
hey et il devient un peu agressif je me
dis bon Lucas tu es une grosse victime
qui fuit tout conflit ou toute situation
malaisante mais là let's go tu as pas le
choix il va falloir gérer ce truc je me
retourne j'affronte ma destinée je
prends les choses en main je le vois il
est méga propre sur lui mais il a l'air
explosé je sais pas s'il est bourré de
malade s'il a pris de la drogue ou j'en
sais rien mais il a l'air éclaté il
s'approche de moi et tend la main pour
prendre mon téléphone frérot c'est pas
une manière de faire
j'étais à deux doigts lui donner
évidemment je range le téléphone dans ma
poche et je lui dis frérot désolé non va
à la FNAC et là il me regarde et il dit
une phrase en arabe moi je vous cache
pas les mots arabes que je connais c'est
starfoullah inch'Allah mais je veux
quand même lui répondre donc je me mets
à lui parler anglais avec l'accent le
même que j'ai dans les vidéos euh sorry
I don't speak Arabic have a good evening
duod qui 180 degrés ça dégage et là il
dit un mot qui résonne en moi
je me fiche et je me dis mais le mec
elle est en détresse peut-être qu'il a
besoin de mon téléphone et là je sors
mon téléphone et j'ouvre Google
Traduction il se met à parler arabe dans
mon téléphone et là la traduction
s'affiche je suis de Dubaï je devais
prendre un train à Gare de l'Est mais on
m'a tout volé ça fait trois heures que
je marche dans Paris s'il te plaît
aide-moi moi moi l'écho sur le moi je
l'ai vraiment eu dans ma tête en lisant
le truc et là je le regarde et je
comprends qu'en fait il est ni bourré ni
drogué il est juste en état de choc
absolu ce qui fait à peu près les mêmes
effets que si tu prends du LSD de
l'alcool et de la weed en même temps et
là il m'arrache mon tél des mains je me
dis oh tout ça n'était qu'une mascarade
et c'est donc bel et bien un voleur et
quelques secondes plus tard il me
remonter les fun et en fait il venait
d'ajouter quelqu'un dans mes contacts et
de lancer une convoits de Save avec lui
et donc je comprends que c'est le numéro
d'un de ses proches et qu'il faut que je
l'appelle pour que ce mec ne vienne en
aide quelques secondes plus tard je suis
en FaceTime avec un mec à Dubaï en haut
d'une tour zéro blague il me dit
me donne pas d'ordre frérot je suis
quand même en train d'aider ton frère
qui est en slip dans Paris à 3h du mat
tu peux juste être un peu poli c'est du
coup je filme mon tél à son Brother les
deux ils parlent 10 minutes 10 minutes
je sais pas tu te rends compte mais il
commence à me péter les couilles j'ai
envie de rentrer chez moi j'ai envie de
dormir 10 minutes plus tard je récupère
mon tél le frère du mec est toujours en
FaceTime et il me dit
bon son action était différent mais il
était à chier comme le mien voilà je me
permets je suis baisé je dois attendre
avec lui le temps que son frère rappelle
puisque ce son seul point de contact
c'est mon téléphone à moi c'est horrible
je suis bloqué mes de l'autre côté je me
dis bon le gars a compris que je venais
en aide à son frère il va faire vite le
frérot dans sa tour à Dubaï il va
bombarder là les appelle la chambre
d'hôtel dans 3 minutes elle est bouquet
40 minutes 40 minutes à essayer de créer
de la complicité avec un mec qui ne
parle pas ma langue heureusement il y
avait Natsu c'est-à-dire on caressé
chacun notre tourne dessous et c'est
comme ça qu'on crée un lien entre nous
pendant ces 40 minutes évidemment
j'envoie plein de messages aux frères du
mec et il y a les deux petits trucs là
de WhatsApp qui montre que le gars voit
mes messages mais que juste tu m'ignores
et pendant ce temps où j'attends
désespérément une réponse du frère du
mec et surtout une adresse pour que je
le foute dans un uber et qui là et son
hôtel et que je recroise plus jamais de
ma vie un nouveau personnage fait son
apparition une meuf habillée tout en
blanc arrive vers nous évidemment moi je
pense à la Dame Blanche je suis pas bien
je me dis ok je vais c'est une
malédiction là je suis en train de me
faire marabouter par des inconnus je
suis foutu cette meuf est donc pieds nus
en robe blanche et en relevant un peu
les yeux jusqu'à son visage je vois
qu'elle a des cheveux très longs noirs
qui lui cache un peu le visage donc ça
me fait penser à the great jasering je
suis pas très à l'aise et surtout elle
pisse le sang de la bouche d'accord là
je me fais un film dans ma tête je me
dis ok c'est un cartel le mec de Dubaï
c'est le chef en fait quand il parlait
arabe il leur demandait l'adresse
précise où on est et leur a ordonné de
me maintenir à cet endroit précis le
temps qu'il envoie un véhicule pour me
kidnapper je vous jure je me dis ça je
suis pas bien je me disais je regarde
Natsu en espérant qu'il me défend des
Natsu il se fait passer le crâne par le
mec de Dubaï alors que je voudrais qu'il
le morde d'accord et quand la meuf
arrive à notre niveau elle tend sa main
et elle dit une clope et quand il dit
clope il y a du son un peu Gigi et là je
vous cache pas c'est la première fois de
ma vie où j'ai regretté de fou de pas
fumer je me suis dit [ __ ] si je lui
donne pas sa clope elle me plante et
après 4 secondes de blanc ressenti 4000
ans dans un geste héroïque mon frérot
Dubaï il sort une cigarette
[Musique]
cette charmante dame arrache la clope de
la main du mec littéralement et elle
repart tout doucement vers l'horizon je
ne sais toujours pas qui est cette dame
je sais pas ce qui lui arrivait gérer
les deux c'était trop dur les gars j'ai
pas mon BAFA bref j'ai à peine le temps
de réaliser ce qui vient de se passer je
reçois un appel vidéo évidemment qui est
au bout du fil le frère du gars toujours
dans sa tour à Dubaï et je décroche et
il dit un truc très rapide il dit OK
attends je comprends pas bien là ça fait
1h je m'occupe de son frère en plus de
ça le mec croit que je vais appeler un
uber je l'ai fait tout de suite à Hubert
berline en plus de ça je mets l'adresse
de l'hôtel dans le Hubert je dis aux
frères c'est bon et là j'ai quand même
eu un
mais merde fais-moi un virement quoi
comme c'est le confinement le Hubert
immédijor Milan arriver à ce moment là
il est genre 4h50 du match je n'en peux
plus la voiture arrive elle s'arrête
devant nous la vitre du conducteur
s'ouvre et le mec dit il est bourré ton
pote là je le prends pas moi il va
Gerber dans ma caisse
et là j'ai été très honnête avec ce
chauffeur là le squeeze gentil victime
il s'est volatilisé je regarde le
chauffeur je lui dis écoute-moi bien ce
mec là il vient Dubaï il a plus de
téléphone plus d'argent plus rien je
viens de passer deux heures avec son
frère hôtel qui était en haut d'une tour
dans l'opulence je t'ai appelé pour
conduire ce mec dans son hôtel à mes
frais et toi tu ouvres la vitre et tu
dis il est mourris ton poil ne prend pas
une nunieux c'est la rare fois ma vie au
jeu de l'autorité sur qui que ce soit
regarde il dit ok fais le monter
et là moi c'est générique de fin
[Musique]
hop fin du générique je réalise que le
mec power m'a même pas dit merci ou quoi
que ce soit il est juste monté dans la
voiture on s'en battant les couilles de
moi et c'est à ce moment que je me suis
dit [ __ ] je suis vraiment une grosse
victime
pourquoi je vous ai raconté cette
anecdotes parce que c'est la seule fois
où déjà j'ai croisé la dame blanche et
où des mecs de Dubaï ont fait de moi
leur esclave en une minute 20 et j'ai
presque aimé ça bref nouvel anecdote
celle-ci c'est la rencontre la plus
flippante de ma vie carrément j'ai
hésité à la raconter tellement c'est un
truc que j'ai très très mal vécu
vraiment c'était il y a 5 mois avec
luciole on venait de partir deux
semaines chez un pote pas en France
vient le moment du retour et le vol
retour c'est un vol relou à 6h du matin
c'est les vols relous parce que la
veille c'est le dernier soir donc
forcément tu vas traîner jusqu'à très
tard et tu dis je dors ou je dors pas
bref nous on a fait le choix de dormir
un cycle donc 1h30 de sommeil on se lève
on est en ramasse il fait nuit je suis
pas bien on dit au revoir à notre pote
et tout on se casse on arrive à
l'aéroport tout se passe bien guichet
passeport sécurité un peu la flemme de
retirer la ceinture c'est pas avant le
fait petit café ah il est dégueulasse
mais quand même et j'en ai besoin mais
direction la porte d'embarquement et là
je me fais pas mal reconnaître parce que
c'est un vol dans lequel il y avait pas
mal de français bon bref des gens sympas
c'est toujours marrant de se croiser à
6h du mat explosé par la fatigue dans un
aéroport dans un autre pays c'est des
moments qu'on aime c'est drôle bref
enfin on est appelé pour monter dans
l'avion enfin je vais pouvoir m'asseoir
et dormir 2h dans la position la moins
confortable de l'histoire l'humanité on
rentre enfin dans la vie avec Lorraine
on arrive à notre ranger la 19 et il y a
un mec qui est assis côté extérieur de
ma rangée et donc on doit passer devant
lui ce moment un peu gênant tu connais
pour atteindre nos places et ce mec
c'est le seul gars de tout l'avion qui
n'a pas de masque mais c'est rien à côté
de ce qui suit j'arrive au niveau du mec
au moment où j'ouvre la bouche pour lui
dire de se lever il me regarde dans les
yeux et il me dit Squeezie tu le sais
pas encore mais tu es un homme mort
rien quand je vous redis cette phrase je
suis pas bien les gars il y a pas de
rire sur son visage et même s'il y avait
un rire c'est juste pas drôle comme
phrase et là j'ai pas le temps de
comprendre ce qui vient de m'arriver que
il se lève et il se pousse pour que
j'aille m'asseoir à côté de lui je vais
passer deux heures assis à côté d'un mec
m'a regardé froidement en me disant
Squeezie tu le sais pas encore mais tu
es un homme mort ou on les adore
les gens ils me dis il a dit ce que j'ai
entendu là et là retour de Squeezie la
victime oui mais c'est une blague et
tout un gros ambiance dans cet avion ça
fait des blagues et tout à 10h du mat et
je regarde le mec lui il est comme ça
Lorraine elle s'assoit au fond côté
hublot moi je m'assois au milieu et lui
ça soit côté rangé on est tous les trois
côte à côte il a toujours pas dit un mot
de plus depuis cette phrase d'accord
juste cette phrase et là je deviens
complètement méfiant parano j'ai
vraiment un très mauvais feeling et je
me dis une phrase il va faire exploser
l'avion c'est pour ça qu'il a dit que
j'étais un homme mort et que je savais
pas encore il va faire exploser l'avion
et Lauren elle qui est la personne la
plus chill du monde elle est là posée
elle sort une feuille elle commence à
dessiner elle en a rien à [ __ ]
dites-vous j'étais tellement panique
c'est pas une blague j'ai fait un truc
horrible pour un proche mais j'ai envoyé
un message à un proche dans lequel je
lui dis il y a un mec qui vient de me
dire je suis un homme mort je sais pas
encore sa tenue c'est ça il ressemble à
ça il a tel âge si jamais quelque chose
m'arrive bah voilà c'était lui le pire
message à recevoir c'est celui-là et
donc du coin de l'oeil je me mets à le
regarder et là ce que je vois ça me
plaît pas du tout le gars il est assis
comme ça il a le signe du stress du pied
qui fait ça il se touche un peu les
mains il se gratte la jambe comme ça ils
jettent des coups d'oeil dans le couloir
comme ça ensuite il regarde l'heure
ensuite il regarde son sac et il fait ça
encore et encore j'ai trop peur de
découvrir ce qu'il y a dans son sac et
j'ai trop peur qu'il fasse vraiment qui
me tue quoi [ __ ] c'est pas normal de
dire une phrase comme ça dans un avion
un mec que tu connais pas c'est pas
normal l'avion à l'école et une fois
qu'on est en l'air il se baisse vers son
sac et il le désire il sort un truc de
son sac un bouquin de philo
et là je me dis mais attends en fait je
suis trop sur la défensive détends-toi
Lucas tu as dormi qu'une heure et demie
ça te monte à la tête là en fait tu le
sais pas encore mais tu es un homme mort
c'est genre une phrase philosophique
qu'un sens profond mais ça m'échappe
parce que moi je suis pas très bon en
philo et là il sort son téléphone et là
je vois le fond d'écran de son téléphone
je l'ai reproduit pour vous c'est ça
ça c'est son fond d'écran de tous les
fonds d'écran qui existent lui il a mis
celui-là et là grosse soulagement il
commence à me parler je vais pouvoir
creuser essayer de comprendre qui est ce
mec qu'est-ce qu'il veut pourquoi il a
un œil de merde en fond d'écran mais je
vous spoil j'ai pas osé lui demander
pourquoi il m'avait dit cette phrase
j'ai préféré croire que ce moment
n'était jamais arrivé n'existait pas et
c'est là que j'ai eu la discussion la
plus chelou de toute ma [ __ ] de vie
selon lui il était en croisière depuis
deux semaines et donc les croisières le
bateau s'arrête dans plusieurs villes
etc les gens descendent il faut une
activité puis tout le monde remonte sur
le bateau un jour l'activité c'était
casino lui il est sorti du casino pour
aller retirer de l'argent sauf qu'il a
un peu tardé et quand il est revenu au
bâton on lui a dit bah non vous êtes
sortis du groupe vous pouvez plus monter
dans le bateau et le bateau est parti
sans lui et s'est retrouvé baiser et
c'est pour ça qu'il était dans ce vol
évidemment moi pendant qu'on discute il
parle et mes réponses c'est
essentiellement des ah mais non ouais
grave grave et puis d'un coup il rentre
dans des sujets un peu plus dip et il
dit une phrase qui me qui me fait un peu
mal il dit non mais tu es quelqu'un si
c'est pour une bonne raison c'est pas
grave
évidemment je suis révolté parce qu'il
vient de dire et je vais lui faire
comprendre que non tu es c'est pas ok si
tu as une bonne raison pas du tout donc
je me tourne vers lui et je lui dis ah
ouais c'est vrai le retour de Squeezie
la victime Let's Go et là les gars il me
raconte des trucs dingues il me dit par
exemple que il est allé voir une escort
sauf que je cite il a pas réussi à
bander à cause du préservatif et ça
traumatisé c'est cool c'est ce qu'il a
dit mot pour mot et là il me regarde un
air très sérieux je m'apprête à ce qu'il
me dise tu as bien compris que tu étais
un homme mort et tu le savais pas encore
mais à la place il me dit il faut que je
rappelle à mes couilles qui elles sont
vraiment
[Musique]
messieurs nous commençons notre descente
vers Paris Charles de Gaulle oui merci
pendant tout le vol les gars j'ai écouté
j'ai répondu j'ai participé au débat de
vie et de société de ce gars juste parce
que j'avais peur qu'il fasse exploser
l'avion c'est bon bref surprise je suis
là l'avion n'a pas explosé en fait le
mec était parfaitement inoffensif mais
juste il était trop bizarre et surtout
je saurais jamais pourquoi quand je suis
arrivé à côté de lui il m'a regardé dans
les yeux il m'a dit Squeezie tu le sais
pas encore mais tu es un homme mort avec
l'air le plus sérieux qui soit le même
air que quand un mec demande à une meuf
de l'épouser quoi c'est un moment
sérieux de fou quoi c'est horrible bref
à toi cher inconnu de l'avion j'espère
que nos chemins ne se croiseront plus
jamais et ben écoutez j'espère que cette
vidéo anecdote vous a plu ça faisait un
an et demi qu'on en avait pas fait je
sais pas si j'ai envie de me souhaiter
de revivre des trucs chelou pour pouvoir
en faire une vidéo non je préfère repart
revivre ces trucs là on fera des vidéos
sur autre chose mais surtout celle de
l'avion là ça m'a vraiment les gars je
vous jure j'étais pas bien quoi ça a
vraiment eu un impact sur moi bref
j'espère que ça vous a plu j'espère que
j'ai bien raconté ça on se retrouve
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo je vous
souhaite de ne pas avoir de rencontres
étranges passez une très bonne journée
soirée matinée nuit peu importe
[Musique]
il était osé celui-là